course okay and since we are before the
lunch i will be very quick
and so i have been discussing uh the um
the topic i'm going to present with um
my long-standing uh collaborator tadashi
and they the people at uiuc and they
also
people here from stanford in the
audience
so i think by now i think i don't have
much
need to introduce tensor networks and
i'll skip
the things and i just want to mention
that um
i mentioned the the the quantum
entanglement comes from this
bond when in the tensor network and the
surprisingly i use the same notation as
mike
for the dimension of the bond chi okay
um so um okay so here's the okay
so um so again i i will talk about the
um
particular kinds of tensor network which
is the
mirror tensor network and they just
again a few quick words about the
two kinds of tensors one is the the the
tensor with three legs that's two
basically decimations
but to represent a quantum ground state
phase three or or accurately we need
these four leg tensors which
basically um untangle the the quantum
entanglement
encode it in the in the target state so
um
um so here's the um the um
kind of uh holographic view we are
discussing many times uh emerging from
the
uh tensor mirror tensor network and that
was uh first discussed by brian
um and the um as mike
uh beautifully explained um the way we
count
the uh we estimate the entanglement
included in the merit tensor network has
a very strong
resemblance with the the the
the way we compute entanglement entropy
in the in the
in the in the holographic setting um
so that's that's much motivates us a
uh uh the conjecture that mira may be a
um
concrete uh discrete realization of a
pornography
okay um so this idea has been
developed since then on on the mirror
side mirror has been applied to
many systems frustrated magnets and they
also um systems with potential
experiment surfaces
which may have more entanglement than
than the the
entanglement in conformer fear theories
and the other are the systems
and the um quite few times mirror always
challenged with other other methods and
the
um inquisitive 1d i guess other other
methods maybe
maybe actually better but a mirror has a
um this
merit of of of representing
the uh idea of uh renormalization group
in
in the quantum meaning body physics
sense okay
so um um so um today i will talk about
the very simple example of mera which is
basically just a free
field and the um that's perhaps will be
a a good thing to look at to settle
some questions raised previously so i
will first describe
a free field construction a free field
theory
mirror for free figure series and they
will describe
finite temperature and the um
application to
a little bit more complicated of state
of matter uh
which is topological insulators okay
um so um i will be using
a a particular uh representation numero
which is
technically uh convenient for me to
manipulate things so i will use the a
continuum
representation of of mirror
so um i have a state which i want to
phase three represent by using mirror
so that is the target state and target
state may be a
ground state a system or maybe ground
state of conformal here so let's say
and the um i i will have a states
whichever call reference state and these
different states
will be chosen as the state with
is essentially no entanglement okay
um so i start from
a tube two point of view i can start
from a reference state
and i act with a mirror network
which represents some sort of unitary
evolution
and the and hopefully that may uh
bring me a state i want which is a
target state
or or going backward i have a target
state and i want to
systematically reduce the number of
degree of degrees of freedom
and entanglement to eventually get get a
state with no entanglements
um so motivated by the
by the the lattice uh mirror
construction
in this continuum version uh proposed by
hegemon etta
uh we have two parts okay so the first
one
uh represented by l does the
spatial derotation it's not a space-time
derotation like in conformer fiercely
but it just derotate
in in space coordinate and there's the
other other part which
take care of this four leg tensor part
of the of the mirror so it is supposed
to remove
entanglement encoded in the in the
targets
uh ground state so um these three
elements
uh actually maybe two elements the the
choice
of this reference state and the
mirror network itself here it is
represented as a
evolution operator and by choosing these
two elements
uh nice way we want to reproduce the
target state pictorially it looks like
this
so um um i put my my state of interest
here in this coordinate which i call you
okay and i put my reference state here
and this is just my choice of convention
okay and
this u operator u which is which i call
mira
evolution period acts on on this state
along this line
okay um so so at this uv
which i i conveniently choose to be zero
here
i have a target state uh with many
entanglement
and mid with many degrees of freedom but
um by acting with you i remove
degrees of freedom as well as
entanglement
or as i said earlier starting from some
trivial state
acting with this evolution mirror
evolution
u i systematically add entanglement
into the state into the system and
eventually i want to get the target
state
okay so that is the um kind of cartoon
of of cartoon picture of the continue
mirror
construction um they uh so
i want to do a simple example of of this
construction
so let me take um um
free theory three fermion dirac fermion
theory in one plus one dimensions
and we know what ground state is so
ground states are nitrated by
a particular combination of fermi
operator where it is
denoted by psi theta and the side theta
is different from this original fermi
operator psi
it's it's it is the one which you get
from the original one by unitary rotate
these fermi operators okay on the other
hand
um so this is the so so for this case of
course we can solve it so we know
the target ground state okay i choose my
my sum
i choose a particular ir state
which is is this state which is
annihilated by psi
and are not inaugurated by psi to dagger
which is the component
of this fermi operator and this state
does not have
any entanglement you can think of this a
a
reference state as a ground state of
of this part of the hamiltonian neuron
you make mass
so large that overcomes the kinetic term
completely so so so there's no special
correlation
uh in this ir state so this is state
as an example of a trivial state
which i want to put at the ir okay so so
um a fixing ir state
what we want to do is to find a uh
operator
which evolve this ir state into the the
ground state i know
okay and they as i described already
uh this evolution operator has two parts
uh one denoted by l and the other
denoted by k
and l basically just do spatial
derotation so if you build me this
operator just
changes the just rescale the special
coordinate or momentum coordinate
since it is a free theory i will assume
um this uh
mirror evolution operator the in
particular the
a entangled part is quadratic
in theory operators okay because
everything should be solvable
in three first three um
so it's quadratic and it depends on
momentum
as well as u which is the coordinate
in the in the vertical direction or bark
direction of the mirror network
and the um for this particular case i
can i can
i can take a certain assumption i mean
this is not actually not my assumption
but this is the original
assumption uh taken by height motor okay
and the the idea is that um this uh
g essentially implements unitary
rotation
okay so if you have a um free field
theory
by rotating your bases
a proper way from let's say psi one side
two
to psi theta side to side 1 to the side
to tilde
you essentially solve your theory okay
um
but here i'm interested in using mirror
to chop freeze fiercely
so in this case what this uh uh this
entangle does
is to act with this unitary operation
uh successively so okay so there's this
series of unitary operations
at each time i rotate my fermion
operator in the right way
okay and repeating this uh um unitary
operation many times we eventually get
the correct uh
fermion ground state okay so this is
what this cut-off function does okay
each time
i do a unitary rotation successively of
course as i said
it's a free field series so if you want
to solve your theory you can do
united rotation all at once okay
but as exercise i'm following the mirror
prescription in that case i do this
rotation successively do you expect
these operators to be approximately
local in position space
that's a good question um
except for capital gamma yeah so um
this part is certainly local
this part is a cutoff function so um
i still i think it's still local and
you can you can certainly add more
polynomials
but uh let's say i will stay in the
local form of the
um i'm reading writing everything in
momentum space but i want to follow the
lattice construction as much as possible
but yeah
okay so here everything is is set it up
so
i should say this correctly reproduce
the uh free fermion ground state okay
but you still have to determine chi and
the chi for example can be
well in this case you can stop your
series so you can determine chi but
for example you can determine chi
variationally but in this case
uh uh either way anyway you get the uh
exact expression for chi okay um
so so so we can solve certainly a free
theory
by using a mirror construction um but
now we want to
uh talk about this the the um structure
of mirror network we have it's written
in the evolution template as
evolution operator but um we want to
pick up some metric which tells you that
properties of the mirror mirror
evolution operator or neural network so
it may in principle differ
and it differs from problem to problem
but um i want to study a
possibly a a space time which emerge
which may emerges from the
mirror construction so to talk about the
a possible space time
or actually just space structure uh i
want to pick up some metrics so here's
just the
one proposal which is um
does what i want to see but it may not
be the unique
solution to this problem but i mean i
define my my um
metric this way so for any given two
states
we can define a distance between two
states
essentially bus just by taking overarch
it sets a distance between two quantum
states
if you have a series of states so let's
say parameterized by some
parameter psi we just take a
infinitesimal version of this
distance and since you have a distance
you you define a metric
okay so um this is just the um this is
just a definition
of metric which works for any quantum
system
similarly you can define connection by
taking the again the overlap
of of two states but in this case i
expand
up to a linear uh difference in the in
the parametric side
so this is the a very general way to
introduce a notion
of a distance and the connection and
this can naturally be applied to
to mirror construction so we have a set
of states now
parameterized by scale u okay
each time you act with a mirror
aberration operator
you get some state and you have a series
of states
each represent a state at a different
energy scale
so by taking the overlap you can define
some sort of metric
okay so as i said this may be a metric
which may be
applicable i mean the proper one to
discuss
horography but this may not be the only
one okay but just as
a curiosity um
okay so let's let's say we define metric
this way take the
um mirror state that at uh
scale u and i compute the uh
overlap between two states defined for
different mirror
energy scales and i i just compute or
define the metric this way
this is a i think it's a good guess but
it's certainly motivated by
by the foreign observation again coming
back to
the estimation of entanglement entropy
because entanglement
entropy should know about the the uh
distance in the bulk um so let's say for
simplicity i cut my network in two herbs
in this case my my entangling surface
cuts through many bonds
many uh uh uh unitaries
for extensors and the um the
entanglement is directly related to the
strengths of the bonds
okay um times up to some scary factor
so um
something we defined as a um distance
or area around this direction should be
related to the strengths
of the of the tensors that we put in in
the
in the in the network and this seems to
be a way to capture such tensors
okay and the similar i think you can you
can have a very similar
structure in the in the canonical
ada cft example so i have a metric here
appearing
uh in computing the entanglement entropy
okay so this is just a just a uh
um the metric i introduced but it does
what
what we want to see for example for the
case of three fermions uh
we can compute the set chi u we can
determine
chi which sit in the in the mirror
evolution operator in such a way that it
reproduces the fermion ground state
exactly
so this is the form of the caillou um
from that we we compute the metric
gu which is the metric in
radial direction in horographic language
and they
um and if i plot this metric uh it does
it does something like this okay so
first of all
i'm starting a massive theory but i can
send mass to be
zero to reproduce conformer fiercely in
this case i
i get the metric which is constant uh
in in this coordinate system which which
is actually what we expect
from the from the uh ordinary ads cfd
uh setting so this is the form of the
metric i have in mind and if this is
constant
uh this represents conformal fear sorry
but we have also the uh
state which is massive if i don't turn
off the mass
i have a method theory and in this case
what happens is that
as mirror evolution operates it
removes some entanglement okay but at
the mass scale
uh state doesn't look like uh entangled
anymore
so the mirror doesn't have to have to
remove entanglement
at the mass scale so eventually the
strength of
of this entangler or this integral
uh reduces to zero so
no entanglement to remove and the metric
is zero so there's no space
okay in this in this in this metric okay
um another thing another exercise we
could do
is is what about finite temperature
okay so finite temperature another way
to think about is to take some of your
double which we already discussed again
and so in the in the mirror tensor
network language
i take two copies of
mirror tensor network because i'm doing
doubling
in the thumb here double sense and you
can combine them in some way
and so for example a free boson
or or free series i can write down a
a states living in a bigger space
in the in the double field space to
reproduce
the thermal state in the original
original
herbal space so here's the uh kind of a
schematic so i have a double helix space
of some coefficient
but if i trace out one state i get a
thermal state
uh in the in which is the original
thermal state which you want to i want
to
represent okay um so
can i build a mirror for this this
summer state
okay and the it is the mixed state but
once i double uh i'm dealing with pure
state
can i construct mirror for this state
um maybe somewhat interestingly or maybe
maybe that's we already expect but this
uh
problem of constructing mirror at finite
temperature is actually related to
a the different problem which is the
quantum quench problem
okay as it turns out so what is quantum
quench
uh it is a time dependent problem so i
start from
um hamiltonian
but at time t equal to zero let's say i
suddenly change my hamiltonian so in
this in this setting
i i start from for example i change mass
as a function of time so so here
let's say mass is finite or big but
eventually i switch off mass
so it's a quench and i quench into
conformal view sorry
okay so this is a quantum quench problem
okay and as it turns out uh
you can view this uh quantum quench
problem
as a uh as introducing a boundary in
conformer fiercery
which was first pointed out by uh
chromobracadi
so um following their their
uh uh prescription we can
write down a um
quantum ground state at a time equal to
zero as
a a conformer invariant boundary state
in conformal theories there which
for the case of free boson looks like
this okay
so um we first saw the mirror
construction
for the quantum quench problem which is
again possible
um but as you can see the
quant states we we talked about in
quantum quench
and the states we talked about in double
figures area are very very similar
okay in fact here and i have a
operator coming from one hybrid space
and the other operator comes from the
the other hero space
but simply replacing this uh a tilde
operator
into the ordinary operator uh i can map
this state
into this state so so by solving quantum
quench problem
um i can also throw up the um uh finite
temperature mirror construction
uh okay um i
i i just want to show you okay maybe
i'll just skip okay so
so i can construct i can construct uh
quantum quench
uh by mirror and then you you can
believe me perhaps it's a free firster
again
and this nicely agrees with um
what again again what we expect from
edscft so this is the double-sided
black hole which showed up a few times
already
um so this is the finite temperature
state
this this geometry is representing a
finite temperature state
and this state you can also get from
some field of field double
construction so starting from a some
euclidean solution
you can sort of analytically continue
into into this geometry
the corresponding state is the sound
field double living in here
and here and there there are a couple
together
um uh two years ago i guess
hartmann martin cena proposed the uh
holographic duo of quantum quench
which is just the half of the of this
this space time
um um the this is exactly what we we did
in the in the mirror uh description
uh so uh again uh finite temperature and
the quantum quench
again this is the uh uh exercise in free
field theory but this seems
fit quite well with what we expect from
the from the
holographic way of thinking
um okay so right how many minutes left
um maybe five and then questions okay
five minutes okay let's say so okay so
far
um i have been discussing three first
example and the it seems like
um although there are three feed
examples
we see some kind of evidence that
there's the quite
a a lot of similarity between fear
series
and the horographic descriptions
um but now as again as we have been
discussing question is
can we deal with something more
complicated
okay certainly we can deal with um
complicated 1d hamiltonian by using
computers for example
but to get some some more intuitions
i i will do the following thing and this
is again
um this part is perhaps a little bit
conjecture okay
okay but but as we have been cons
considering a generic construction
of mirror for generic conformer viewers
here let's say
what we can say about this so um um
so again mirror network consists of two
pieces
the choice of reference state and the
choice of
um um mirror evolution operator so
so rather than throwing both i just
focus on the the i'll just talk about
the choice of ir
state okay so the for the free terminal
example
uh region in terms of color basis
uh this reference state actually uh
takes the
essentially the form of conformal
environment boundary conditions
okay so omega can be thought of as a
boundary states in conformer fiercely
which are
for some people they're the the family
object
in discussing boundary critical
phenomenons
okay um so if you think of a boundary
state
boundary state as it turns out has a a
maximal entanglement
in left and right moving sectors of the
theory
but you think about the uh entanglement
included
as a as a real space correlation
boundary state essentially has no
no nuclear space entitlement unlike cfd
ground state
boundary state doesn't support the
entanglement
which scares us a as a separation of two
regions and b
oh sorry it doesn't scare us the
uh size of the region a
which appears as a bipartition so it
seems
that boundary state may be a good
candidate to
to to take as a uh
reference state or ir state for generic
conformer fiercely
this is just a proposal but it is true
that boundary state doesn't have much
entanglement
okay um so but there's another another
another piece of mirror network which i
have to construct so i have to now
evolve from a boundary state into
a ground state of conformal fiercely
which i don't know how to solve it
yet but i can certainly consider
a at least smooth way to connect
boundary stage
on the ground states of conformal fear
series so i just
evolved with the hamiltonian which
children actually already mentioned
so we just let the uh if i just do a
imaginary time evolution
because hamiltonian eventually select
the ground state
uh we eventually get the grounds to the
hamiltonian the the kind of a
um the thing which may look
which looks quite different from the
ordinary mirror construction is is that
this operate around
is not a unitary so you have to rescale
each time you operate with mirror below
evolution operator
it does it's not a conserving norm um
but i just want to do a simple exercise
so so at least in this way i can connect
boundary state
and the ground state of conformal
fiercery and following the recipe i
talked about
i can define some sort of metric so i
can compute
this overlap between states at different
mirror energy scale and at least the the
end result is is what we
we expect so for in free field theory in
d dimension
this metric goes like uh boring of the
system divided by some cutoff
up to to the exponential d u these are
dimension
and u is the the the mirror scale
in one plus one dimension cft we have
essentially the same structure except
central charges appearing here so
um that's roughly what expect
but as i said i i don't i don't know if
this is what
what is really like a uh mirror for
generic conformer of your theory
but i think as ir state a boundary state
is qualified as a good reference
state to build a mirror construction
so i guess i don't have much time so
maybe i just skip here and they um
yeah so um for free for fear series
we we see some features which are very
similar to
um horographic consideration
maybe which we we shouldn't expect
because we are talking of free field
series
but nevertheless they are very striking
a similarity between free field
uh mira and the and the
ordinary um holography
um so to solve the um
to construct a mirror for more
complicated
interacting systems which is necessary
if we want to study a condition uh
for which the uh holographic dictionary
works like a large central church
the gap in the in the scaling dimensions
and so on so forth
or maybe the emergence of locality in
which may
uh uh happen in in the proper limit
we want to have mirror uh constructed
for
interacting systems okay so um
i don't think we have a very concrete
result yet but
boundary state as ir city may be a good
start
so that's my conclusion but that's also
the question to you because that's
something we have been discussing
so what is the uh uh generic
construction
of of interacting conformal piercers
using
mirror average okay thank you very much
i'll stop here
i can't resist asking to say a couple
more sentences about the last
point there topological phases right so
so
um so i have been thinking i have been
discussing ir state as a completely
entangled state
but when we when we when it comes to
topological phases there's a kind of
question
can i really use um completely
uncorrelated product
state as a as a ground set because after
all
the uh definition almost the definition
topological phase
is that it cannot be connected to
trivial state
by using local unitary transformations
and in fact if i just take
simplest topological insulator and they
just learn
mirror method so this is the example
simplest two two-band two-dimensional
fermion model which shows topological
properties if i just run
a mirror procedure what i found was that
it is not possible to use product state
as irsis then you will fail miserably
okay so what happens is that i compare
two states
so this state i think i hope this
notation is clear enough so i have a two
bands like side one side two as in the
one my one plus one the example
and i i feel all second states
and i just take this as the example of
trivial state no special correlation
um so if i take this state and i compute
the the distribution of a very
connection
or rather the very curvature which i
already defined
um it doesn't reproduce the the the
the very curvature of the target state
so we fell if we replace this uh
kind of naive guess by something a
little bit more complicated so it's
somewhat
winding uh as it turns out we can
reproduce
uh a chan insulator by using mirror and
here's kind of picture
of not the metric but the the flux so
the i
i would say perhaps another motivation
to think about this kind of model is
that
if you think about horography it's not
just a metric but there's some
some charge field in the bulk so
topological
phase may be an interesting uh venue to
study the
the laurel charter field but but for the
case of
of trigger work state uh the very flux
essentially gets reflected back
somewhere
and the total berry curvature at the
target state turns out to be zero which
we shouldn't
because we want to get a topological
phases of matter
which supports non-zero berry coverage
if i choose this stage this flux line
coming out of
out coming out from the the target state
kind of absorbed
into a different state reading at the
air state
so that's that's what i meant by a
topological phase may be related to some
charged object
living in the block so that suggests if
you took a quantum spin hall state or
something where the net
very curvature is zero effectively right
right so we haven't tried but maybe
there's some symmetry restrictions if i
allow
the mirror to break exactly exactly yeah
yeah
other questions
i think your question will go earlier to
the
part about the
the metric for summer double state
ah okay
just does that no
okay so this is the metric for quantum
quench sorry i mean the sum of that
sum of double state that's the same as
same metric as this because we use the
same
um we essentially use the same
descent angular for both for quantum
quench and
you got a different measure you got a
metric that's exponential in
one-hour beta
exponential of l over beta i mean it's
not always from the integral
i mean you mean here oh sorry
uh yeah this is supposed to be just the
integral
um
if i now if i do that i i get a one over
i don't get the expression
why not because i have e here here in
the scene 2.02
i thought this is right but maybe i'm
wrong
yeah i cannot do this in my head
yes
it's very very singular um
you took some specific state right i
took specific state and
and i don't i don't really okay so i
have to say i don't really understand
the nature of the state
um the it's singular it may be actually
get press okay um
but the uh so far this is the uh
one possible state which we which we
found
we can use to disentangle topological
insulator
but there may be a bit of better
candidate which avoids single rdi
i don't know at this point
on the lattice we have exact that's
right that's right yeah i should mention
that
right right all right the chiral state
right right right yeah i should mention
that actually it's in here but i skipped
that
sorry yeah
people have you getting hungry if there
are no other urgent questions
let's sanction said